there you go
oh boy I don't like that why is there
blood
hello everybody my name is Markiplier
and welcome back to the USG ishimura
where am I oh I'm here I know where I am
I need help so bad I need I need to
store so bad all right safe I also have
not been using my big Blaster gun which
is something that I'm hoping to rectify
almost immediately store
please store
hi
why you be so grumpy all the time
Orchestra
and something not jumped out at me soon
enough that you're just getting all
itchy
there's got to be a store over this way
oh I think there's also a stasis in here
that I can restock on
I do not use stasis enough I feel like
that's one of my biggest weaknesses in
this is not equipping myself a stasis I
know I just ran into the new enemies
that no longer benefit from I was
pushing a box that no longer benefit
from stasis but uh
I feel like I could be a little better
about that
hello
uh Goodbye Oh
what's gonna pop up oh behind me what's
gonna pop out of me
I've got a funky feeling
Something's Gonna
why
why you be so kaboomy
so this good it's all this good I have
no more plasma cutter ammo which is bad
I have no Health which is even bad there
I have eight notes
oh God damn
what I am that's what I need
all right let's go see what I can node
up I think there's a workbench right
over here and health please thank you
one more
wow I meant almost full health wait what
how long has that been there
all right let's go ball
eight nodes God damn I'm swimming in
nodes
uh
could be good
um air probably not size you know what
it's finally time to increase the size
we're going maybe not that big uh plasma
only capacity and reload that's fine
this one damage is so far away but
there's these rate of fire would be good
and ammunition capacity it's all right
what about my big kabumi which I never
use
primary fire who cares
capacity 15 is good actually it's I'm
I'm doing okay which is shocking hey why
not I'll Splurge a little on the size
why not
and I guess I could do a little more
reload on this
and it bugs me that it's at 19 and not
20. so there we go I'll hold off on the
rest until I get another upgrade for one
of these other devices
yeah that'll be good that's good enough
right there
all right on the way we gotta go to the
crew deck which is just across the
hallway here I think
also what about my side objectives it
was the whole thing about the master
I can get
near tram maintenance where
oh through the crew
will all right then
I'll do that hello
okay this is now new territory
I've not been here before so any bodies
on the ground are probably gonna try to
kill me
foreign
wow
is that so
do tell
fascinating
oh
oh it's dark in here
okay
I would have thought that the crew deck
would have just gone right to the crew
quarters
I thought it would have gone right to
where people live but apparently not
oh
okay
we have over here
oh this dork
these door oh
hey who
what
why go go oh no but you're barely
nothing
you're nothing
there are a whole lot of nothing
excuse me had a hiccup
isn't that all of them
is that not all of them
build master security override that
sounds really cool and awesome
where do I do that
the captain's Nest okay that's right
around the corner too well this is
weirdly convenient almost like it was
designed this way okay Captain's nest
and then rebuild the master security
override which should allow me to
basically unlock anything on the ship
I don't imagine that there could be
anything left but those those random
Master security things were all over the
ship
I don't know what super goodies are
going to be there but it's got to be
worth it at some point
also kind of selfish of them to keep the
Escape pods only up here
oh poor Hammond got disembow created
yes
okay nice and what's this uh guide to
unitology kept it right by his chair
that's so cute
all right
so I don't know where the first thing of
these would be and I don't know what the
benefit would be I gotta check my map to
be able to know where these are
well that doesn't sound good
that doesn't sound good at all
okay so that's the crew quarters I
haven't gone there yet
more crew quarters
I'm supposed to go there
uh-huh
more crew quarters
I haven't gotten there crew quarters is
huge well I guess there's a lot of
people that probably live on the ship so
I imagine the crew course the crew
quarters is huge change Mission okay
find report on Bridge
find report on bridge for what oh
computer says in Nicole filed the report
on the bridge about what Harris did in
ore storage
where is it
find report it's here
find report on the bridge what do you
mean
what do you mean report on the bridge
I report on the bridge
[Music]
fine then we'll waste more time and
record this
satisfied
no I'm not satisfied we have a dead
Miner we we can't sedate bran Harris
wasn't Harris originally your patient
you've warned us that he could berserk
Captain Harris is suffering from a
dementia that we don't fully understand
he was making progresses of Dr Mercer
took his case over my objections
and frankly this this Vendetta against
Dr Mercer just sounds like more of your
bigotry Mike what do you deny that
you've counseled members of our church
and turn them against unitology I'm
telling you the person's treatments are
moral and dangerous and why does he keep
taking hairs to Hydroponics
medical is a sanctuary not versus
private lab so stop covering for him or
accusations still
you know your way out
he won't stop Brad Harris Captain you
know that
I think he knows that and wants that
all right I found the report on the
ridge
lovely convenient Hydroponics okay well
that takes me a little bit away but this
side quest is
me a little curious
I can't deny I don't know why I'm going
to the store it's not like anything
changed from the last situation
yeah it's probably worth it it's
probably worth it it's probably worth it
I'm gonna go I'm gonna try that I'm
gonna see Hydroponics plus there I have
the master security override now so it
would be worth it because I know that
there was a master security thing
towards the back of the ship I don't
know if it was specifically in
Hydroponics but
why not right
why not
Hydroponics
yes please
let me actually before I get going on
here I'm going to check the map
so I don't waste my time and miss any
sing them abobs okay there's nothing
here
or zero
six floors oh there's one
it's right up the way there okay well
that's good to know
one there
oh what is that
important oh that might be the that
might be the actual thing that I'm here
for I forgot that I'm not just here for
master override stuff okay it just seems
like it's just in the door and then
there's something else that's just
around the bend
which is great
hi bathroom I don't like you
okay I think it was just over here
there better be something good in here
there it is whoa
okay
Security card
whoa
you didn't tell me that there would be
weapon upgrades in there oh interesting
so that's got to be the only place to
get further weapon upgrades maybe even
like a suit upgrade would be there let
me try this I think it's probably there
yes it is all right
I'm ready for it no accidents just oh I
was
I didn't know you could blast through
that all in one go oh that makes me feel
special
makes me feel talented and cool
oh hello I missed okay
that's a little silly
all right he's afraid of me which is
understandable I'm very scary
oh
anything here node great
oh my no no way no no no no no no no no
no
ah get off of me
well that went poorly
all right there's got to be oxygen
around here somewhere
hello
hello oxygen please
here the worst places to work discreetly
yeah
that would never be allowed near medical
and now
remember your last brain surgery stasis
for consciousness
quite useful
if only I hadn't wasted so much osmium
on my last module design
did it
oh wait
oh
and perhaps
it's time for your first real hunt
oh good prototype spaces module
um
what does that do
prototype stasis model no that's the
upgrade
uh
okay but this is also in the crew deck
which I think I just need to
what do I do with it
what do I do
oh boy
wow pathetic pitiful hi you're probably
less pitiful but I'm still not impressed
oh this is not a weapon give give come
on get come on it's right there all
right the old-fashioned way
I try to conserve ammo I really do but
it doesn't give me much of a chance
oh great
well that was useful but I well hello
Wham
was that the only one
aesthetic
no match for Isaac Clark incredible man
all right so the question is should I go
around and try to get all the master
security key things
believe
hey what are you doing here what are you
doing here
wow that was really sad
only a hundred credits barely even worth
the bullets Okay so
how do I use this stasis thingy
open upgrade maybe I gotta go a bench
man my inventory is getting full
hey whoa whoa
whoa whoa whoa hey wait what hey hey wow
there's no need for any of that
anyone else
that's what I thought
hey holes
did I get all that
oh go go ghost okay
if I'm not mistaken this connects to
like the mining engineering decks which
had like a door if I remember
it was like a door
it's in their door
no but I swear it was just on the inside
here so I'm gonna pop in just real quick
I'm right here I'm right here I might as
well I'm gonna pop in just look
because I I swear like right in there
was a door
check station when farting
all right there's two doors mining deck
was it mining or was it engineering
I feel like it was just right around
here
maybe not no engineering's different
let me check oh where's that engineering
so there is one on engineering it's
right there so there is something in
engineering
oh yeah
there's a yeah yeah
oh interesting I don't use that one but
very interesting
Ripper
and no indication of
Stacy oh I have the nodes Emma as well
damage out of it always useful always
always useful always useful
always useful very useful probably
I think that might have been the only
one here but it did say that there was a
level two room that I haven't been in so
I might as well just
find that
oh hello
thank you clearance
thank you
no but maybe
Hawk a schematic for an oxygen tank oh
damn that would never have been useful
node all right good thing I went down
here okay I think that's all for
engineering
but there's still whoa no that's a pipe
I think there's still something in the
mining deck
I'll be right back
[Music]
I think it was just around the corner
here
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah
yes please
there's also thumping in here
hey what are you doing
try me try try it Daria
oh that is the thing that I use that is
that thing
all right hell yeah
let me just do a quick scan of the
floors here nope
what this is in the the abyss
is also in the abyss what is this
supposed to be okay
I don't know what that's about but I
think I got everything that I needed so
I can get out of here
all right
oh there probably is
I'm just gonna look at the map
if it's super out of the way I'm not
gonna do it but since I'm headed back
anyway probably not worth it
oh really
malfunction please stand by
uh-huh
you did that trick already you did that
to me already I'm not fooled
unless it's like right around the corner
I'm not gonna worry about it
don't even matter I'm out here I'm Audi
I ain't going to Medical there probably
is in medical but medical sprawling
I'm going to the bridge
well I'm going to the crew deck which is
where I was supposed to go a long time
ago
but good thing lyxian made that all
short and sweet and succinctive just a
montage of my successes and nothing else
ready looks in good great glad
ah contact beam no special ability
what do we have here
speed three have I been able to get SP2
oh I don't think I've gotten that yet
really increases size oh wow I thought
this already did that
size of secondary fires projectile this
is size of explosion well I have just
enough for that
I gotta use that
one that uh that seems like something I
need
you know what let's bust out deal go
away elevator let's bust out the old
what was it called lion cannons Cannon
cannons floaties floaty man explode
splodster the big splodster that's
that's what it was
right oxygen tank very useful lots of
full Med packs God damn God damn my
inventory is almost full God damn all
right we're finally back on on track
only a slight detour
but now we're all good
all very very good
whoa who why what happened
what is going on
it's above me isn't it all right well
you're gonna get a face full of contact
contact
I thought I heard something else
turns out I did not
yeah and there was a bench right here
huh that's convenient don't need it
though
somehow from going unlimited nodes where
I didn't need upgrades I suddenly need
more nodes
I think I'm losing you something on the
crew deck must be interfering with the
signal I can guess what that something
is if the marker is active [__] the crew
deck is locked down but the deck
supervisor might have an override key
the last location I have for her is the
gym how long will it take to install the
singularity core on that shuttle not
long if no one tries to stop me hurry
you can't leave the marker in their
hands
you're right about that you're so right
you've never been more right in your
life
well that was the last tram location so
so here luggage
wine
we'll be drinking wine over here
finally last place on the ship I have
yet to be
dork
oh hi I don't trust any look no
personalies but uh this is not
acceptable
is extremely unacceptable this is so
beyond unacceptable
I cannot accept any of this
not happening
no
I don't care what the unitologists say
about desecration of corpses
[__]
and there we have it
wait can I not get in here well I've got
master override damn it I'm so pissed
right while my master override's not
good enough I guess I'll just save and
move on
okay
what
what's going on
what's up
the gym you say
locker room and challenge uh-huh
well I've never met a bathroom I didn't
like on this ship
definitely not
nothing no there's something
thank you thank you Clarence why can't I
carry oh my inventory is full oh my God
no but my inventory is full
oh wait can I use my little
there we go oh my God Advanced oh my God
I'm going to get this
oh my God 60
000. I can't afford that uh I'd have to
sell some of these Health packs but why
would I risk that
level five fine
excellent stuff see the trick is I just
never take any more damage from this
moment on
wow
look at me
holy crap I'm armored to the tits well
and I'm [__]
but I'm armor Rich all right let's do
this let's do this
oh wait there was more stuff in here
now that I can actually hold it
stays back probably useful
more really more
[Music]
I know this seems weird
I'm not having more of you guys
come back when I least need it
all right good enough
interesting
text log
use the Kinesis module to grab the ball
and shoot it into the Rings before the
timer runs out beating each level yields
a reward that can be cleaned from the
lockers when the center of the Ring
lights up the target for that ring is a
score multiplier
label oh boy I always did love this one
that's a wonderful one
again
where's the bowl oh
yay
are any of these lit up I can't even
tell
[Applause]
what hey wait what score multiplier wait
where
you're about to get a face full of
contact
well that seemed unnecessary
well another one
[Applause]
why did I not use the contact part whoa
wait a minute how many of you are there
where are you ow
hey I'm supposed to not take any more
foreign
[Applause]
easy
I definitely have time for this
oh whoa whoa
oh
thank you
there we go did I do it
I score mode
yippee oh
congratulations thanks
very worth it and this seems important
that's a lot of lockers
see one
thank you oh thank you oh thank you oh
thank you oh thank you oh thank you
oh thank you very much
oh thank you
I'm guessing I was supposed to go up
there
but what was over here wasn't this just
the other way to go in here yeah
okay well that was a good diversion this
is the episode of diversions but it's
okay guys I'm having fun that's what
this guy oh man more corpses they really
did just um
fertilize everybody
not a not a person alive
okay executive shuttle you're all mine
man this was almost too easy
I love this gun
as guns dope
I think I might have taken some space
contact
oh I do take some Splash damage maybe I
shouldn't increase the size maybe maybe
I shouldn't have done that
but it's just so effective
oh you're not supposed to be there
ah too bad for you I'm too smart oh
hey don't
oh it was one of those things
oh oh well it's you hi oh no corpses
left oh no corpses no no carp seeds for
you
oh that's so sad I'm so sad
where did you go there are you come here
that's terrible that's just awful who
are you done such a thing not me for
sure not me oh man so full so loaded
loaded with ammo
just loaded and health I'm just I'm
doing incredibly
I don't think anyone's ever done as good
as me in this game ever in history
forever
oh
but what's on floor three
but I want to know what's on floor three
everything's on floor three so many
things are on floor three
I'll just do what it says floor one I
like floor one
and I like this being done
hello
take Assurance don't go It Alone take
Assurance all right
let's say
usefulness
Mercer
still alive it's the clock
I'm still denied conversions thanks for
this increase Mercer wait
tell me
I want to understand
what is Convergence
but you already know
dead or living
we all feel
Marcus to the purpose
don't you want to be reunited
but the people you lost
hi
yes
then why not
it's the temple
has fused
of the assaults
everything
that has happened
when you put it that way
and your marker can go to hell
slow death
s
well I think your death
how about your death with a full blast
contact beam right to the Dome
oh hey wait a minute you hold on there I
want you to taste this
oh wait one more
all right cool good just just checking
all right what am I supposed to do here
hey those are useful I should not take
those Point Blank you stay there stay
just stay down
uh we got one of these are you getting
up
never mind I played a lot of basketball
to practice that and it just did not
work out as I thought it might
can you not exist
where am I going
stay there
lockers I like lockers
okay
where am I going
where did he go
hey wait a minute
am I just supposed to fight him a few
times because I don't see anything oh
wait no
wait what just explain oh
oh I see
okay so there's gotta be yeah nope
where is it God damn I gotta be
somewhere
where are they going back to
oh where are they okay you you you hold
on
where are they that
no
oh they all look like bulbous
to mess away
oh oh I'm dumb I wasn't even supposed to
go in there
all right
what
dollars for practice another working
around here
uh Johnston and Chen as in the pilots
from the shuttle that much
I think everything's gonna be just like
it was
hmm
what is that objective I don't know what
that objective is I'm not 100 sure with
that objective someone translate that
for me does it make us whole or
something like that
I don't know is it dead in space Oh God
please tell me it's not dead in space
okay
okay interesting
fascinating
oh boy oh
huh
yeah I wish I could talk
oh
sorry about everything huh
I don't know why you're sorry but
are you sorry for me smashing on your I
completed an objective what did I do
you're the weight of
oh wait
oh what was over here then
wait a minute but what was over here
then
huh
no problem
oh no it was a trap
it was all on the elaborate ruse that I
both didn't fall in and then immediately
fell into
so I'm both smart
and dumb at the same time
which makes me a genius of some kind or
something like that probably
what hey none of that
oh my God
uh Kaboom oh God oh God this is a job
for the contact beam get contacted get
contacted get contacted
oh God you're not contacted you're still
not contacted
how are you still not contacting me
wow
that could have gone better
Ruby I like Ruby
door
man if these corpses could stop
Whispering at me that'd be great I think
at this point I don't really need to buy
much of anything besides power nodes to
finish out my upgrade paths so I think
I'm okay to buy that
I think anyway
there's some talkative Corpses
oh yeah
oh wait but there are still things how
are there still things well I'd like
some ERG duration would be lovely
that's weird
how are there still things that I
haven't gone is there a level six suit
I'm gonna get that suit
I'm gonna get it
[Applause]
okay destroy the 10 drill
all right 10 drill nude
10 drill anybody seen a 10 drill
oh boy why what is that contact
God damn this is supremely effective
see monsters
can you uh shut up
Isaac
symptoms
Mania illusion
what was the last strongest
[Applause]
we
would have killed
but you too
oh
I usually can't clear out a thing like
that but I did am I going this way I am
going that way but before I go that way
to mess hall
uh nothing nothing nothing nothing
nothing a whole lot of nothing
um
uh Zoomy Zoomy
that must just be the way back I'll get
in a second
all right oh
oh
pray
oh good
whoa whoa whoa what is the deal
man I'm wasting time here
I don't have time to waste let me switch
back to just this and let me get another
breath dude hold on I wasn't ready for
that whoa
I hear something in there
what am I hearing
what's going on
oh
[Applause]
oh you oh why
see oh there we go
oh my God what was that
oh you did already
ah maybe
oh God another one
okay you're dead um I need
to figure out what the hell is I'm doing
here before I die oh oxygen that's very
handy
what is the sounds
oh hey it's a tendril
oh God
oh my God okay you I didn't expect you
to be there
take that and that and some this is
stuck on me
it's literally stuck on me oh wow my gun
is stuck in that okay well this is this
isn't in any way inhibitory storage room
I like that is this where I'm supposed
to go no where are you okay this
I have this now it's my shield
don't worry
you gonna come out for me in there
okay thank you I need that
coming up and blast him with one of
these
oh node
yes please
I think that doesn't get me
take two mess hall but I feel like
there's more stuff in here that's just
hidden
one of these
this
again with one of these oh there he is
all right that seems about it I'm going
uh goodbye
yeah take your time oh
what
oh
can I can I throw those projectiles back
at him I would really like that that'll
be really cool
I'm taking you with me
okay intense a little bit intense little
bit kind of kerfuffly
not a cop this
oh I don't have a power block
okay where is a power block
ish that's a good question I have no
idea I don't think it would say that on
my map would it nope
um I don't recall even seeing a power
block
unless there's one in that uh there
might be one in the gas in here
so it's gonna take another quick scan
are you in here oh you're in here aren't
you
foreign
I don't know it wasn't in the bathroom
for sure
nope
not there
it's there there it is
clear
I don't feel like something's right
behind me
taking this with me
easy enough probably uh definitely was
good use of that
to use on him
definitely all right in Deluxe quarters
hmm
okay
great I don't know why that happens on
this ship I don't know why when
everything else goes to hell that fans
just lose their mind and decide to
self-destruct well you know pretty cool
all peace
manport Temple
that is unfortunate
Dr cross is going to be very very sad
okay
all righty then
oh one hit of the store
Uno count meds actually doing okay on
everything the only thing I don't have
is like an extra stasis pack it would be
nice considering that guy is roaming
around
oh it's by two they are cheap I don't
know why I don't use
it I don't know why I don't use them
very much I feel like damn I mean well
necessary sometimes hi Bill important
uh Deluxe quarters
we're the rich rich is good
find the shuttle do you need to install
the singularity
I know
y'all I know oh god oh
no power huh
oh boy yep that's that's what I figured
where are you stop
whoa
ah no I thought I might be able to catch
that
quarantine lifted thank you very kind of
you
extremely kind actually
okay
Deluxe quarters
[Music]
it's probably not good
oh boy hey what's up bud
oh my God that got you good
I forget that these things like killing
one hit there's like one supreme
impactful hit
Who's laughing
are you laughing at me you wouldn't be
laughing at me would you
oh you think that I'm worth laughing at
oh you think that this is one big okay
Deluxe bathroom great how Deluxe we
talking oh still no doors on these
is uh stalls oh
that Deluxe huh that's so um
Deluxe there's really nothing in this
bathroom
ah man okay
all right well this was totally
pointless
can I have that
okay
bad
Isaac huh sorry late shift how are you
I am
my mother she's some Octavia
how's she doing
she's dead Nicole
they both are
she killed my dad then herself
[Music]
the church
they took the bodies before I get up oh
my God
[Music]
oh Isaac I'm
sorry
stop it just stop talking
you said she was herself again
she said she would be better at home
a Jew
God
you might as well have killed him
yourself she was better
you told me to leave for the ishma right
you you pushed me
you know what
Nicole
I didn't
[Music]
oh God no
not here too
Isaac
[Applause]
[Music]
it's me
yeah
you talk
sorry I can make it right I'm sorry
I can save us both how about everything
oh good good also they managed to get
one of the explodey dudes in an x-ray
that's awful
these look terrible I hate these
um okay well that uh was sad
um
very sad
weapon upgrade
is it recording
can't miss anything
there's just cruelty oh my God
deciphering how the marker signal
affects the brain
Dr Brennan
let me guess
Terence kind literally
shame he's not here he
didn't understand how this tragedy
represents a chance to cure death
go on
these creatures
reanimated tissue cellular immortality I
I know we've never seen eye to eye but
I understand now
there's
so many I
should have saved
because
you've learned how to communicate with
the marker
I'm so close I thought it must have the
secrets that I need
you are a woman of science
nothing
leave the market to me
these are your
autopsy notes
very thorough
you'll need them peer-reviewed of course
and poor Terrence
isn't here to help you
yes
there's only one man I trust now
and useful
for Mr Harris's next surgery
okay
no really what does that mean what is it
what does that mean what do you mean no
related rig activity has been logged is
that the end of the line did I do
something
I did it I did it I don't know what I
did
well all very very interesting
still laughing huh okay I said don't
that don't sound cool that sounds bad
okay so I've been in the deluxe
bathrooms and then that room they've
been very Bountiful except for the
bathrooms that was basically nothing
so I'm gonna go in the quiet bunks
shushums
everybody shishams
huh uh don't do whatever you're gonna do
I hate the laughing laughing is not good
laughing is not good oh oh oh boy oh oh
wow oh
uh okay all right I'm
okay well I don't need to see this okay
kind of sucks but
okay
hey whoa
well no baby I thought the dude was
rising from the dead
thank you
all right well here's a power doohickey
I do need this
gonna Chuck it down the hole for the
moment
I just wanted to try something see if
any of those are removable weirdly uh
just a crazy thought yeah
I don't think there's anything down
there
someone's a grumpy
that's what I thought you'd think you
can pull fast ones on me
out of here
hey wait a minute
well not that
give me the goody I love that you're
going for the weapons I really do but
there's a
I really appreciate you going for the
weapons I really do because I'd rather
that happen in a fight than literally
anything else
doors or lights how lights are the
lights here
that's it no better no better actually
no not better
that's not what I want
is that the big guy
am I hearing big man
fine
shift bunks
okay
oh
[Music]
I didn't want that okay I
that was a good room
good room
not a cup
good
someone translate that for me
oh hey that's convenient
flamethrower man if I ever use that
that'll be really cool to have
I still haven't found the tendril where
the hell is the tendril
it's in the deluxe quarters
oh
there it is
well you know
I feel like oh
God you're a Twitchy one
you freeze right there buddy
ah oh my God where did you even come
from
baby
what happened
where did all these [__] come from
okay I gotta go here
I go here
I don't know where I go
or it's not just a baby
I'm assuming oh come on door come on
there you go no thank you am I going
this way yes I am executive quarters God
this is taking me a little bit to find
these things but oh well oh Al ass
I need to sell some [__] and I need to
upgrade some [__] and I don't think
there's a bench around here and I don't
know what's going on and I don't know
anything
yeah I got two of these things that
could be two beautiful nodes
I'll just waiting till I come across
another bench so I'm sure they'll give
me one
well I can't go that way can I get this
yes I can no I can't yes I can yes I can
this one
oh
ah
all right executive quarters
what have you got for me my friend is
this what you hope for when you signed
your life the way to the church
assistant
Carnage look like Transcendence I don't
know what lies Beyond Death not anymore
but I do know our lives are more than
just fuel for convergence if we work
together we can fight this evil
it's not too late
please
uh wow oh
great
so uh Captain uh you make this yourself
you can hear me from the bizand
from unidentified confidential Fleet
position confirmed referencing our
pre-departure discussion I am blessed to
report that the vested have authorized a
premium stasis capsule for you aboard
the church's holy Fleet congratulations
your generous donations over the years
have already covered all post-mortem
stasis and cryo preservation fees while
I cannot guarantee which Arc will
safeguard your physical body all Fleet
vessels are designed for centuries of
deep space operation and equipped with
state-of-the-art defense technology
ensuring that convergence will proceed
without interference when the holy hour
approaches I must reiterate that this
birth is conditional upon the successful
completion of your pilgrimage once the
marker is safely delivered into church
hands and all electronic records have
been appropriately amended I will be
pleased to finalize your resting place
amongst the Trisha's Most Blessed
including Altman himself wow all right
Phoebe
go on Phoebe
go off
proud of you peeps thanks peeps but it
looks like the cabin won't be joining uh
Captain joined uh conversions way way
early like super duper early what's
going on here
what are you hiding
hmm
mining accidents oh it's just some
casual reading about mining accidents I
see ah
here I was just
not reading that
all right Dr White who's Dr White I'm
not the guy that made Mega Man
all right
um goddamn oonies are running the ship
so far as I know that's a lot of them
not many senior officers just happen to
be marker heads can't be a coincident
coincidence I know a stack deck when I
see it check some files a lot of the
reassignments started after director
Eckhart got chatty with the captain
since when does the c-suite give a damn
about Personnel I don't know when does
the sea Suite give a damn about
personnel
but I'm assuming you're right and you
know what you're talking about
all right story story story
well who blocked this
oh
that's so sad
oh executive bathrooms oh I can't wait
to see what this is all about
oh my
oh that's not good hey what's this
thank you
oh
there you go
oh boy
let me out here
die
what did you not like that
[Applause]
what oh God no no
hold still there I got some for you whoa
what are you doing stop what did I miss
contact
anybody else
but
that's what I always suspected
just a bunch of cowards
can't take me in a stand-up fight so
they gotta try to Ambush me
Perth Eric
hello oh another one
gold is that it no
what what hey how did you get there
I don't know why that was in there who
could sleep with that fuse going up by
their head
uh
well why did
what was it
did that go here oh it did go here
oh this is this is better than the
Captain's Quarters
it seems like unnecessary luxury what
he
is that a puzzle
is there a puzzle in there
what does that mean it looks like
footprints
eight
hand hand
foot hand and foot yeah foot hand hand
foot foot eight I don't know what the
eight means though there was that room
full of arms and legs which was kind of
weird is that pertinent that's very
strange okay let me go to this last
place and then maybe I'll try to solve
maybe I'll try to solve that I don't I
don't understand
maybe it's like a dance move I gotta do
a certain number of backflips and
handstands
foreign
has that always been there
has that always has that always been
there how have I noticed that
how have I not noticed that if that's
always been there has that always been
there
has that always been there
how have I not noticed that that was
it okie dokie then
I'm probably fine probably fine
at least I can go over here now
all these lovely tendrils
uh
will we now
and is this really the time to profess
your love for me I'm Dr Terence kind oh
hi remember we spoke on the valley
you're real let me in I need to destroy
that cluster behind you not yet but
escape on that shuttle and you'll kill
us all
when they took the marker from ages
seven they woke up being in the core of
the planet
oh
[Applause]
the hell is that
Mercer calls it the hive mind
Nexus Market is how much controls these
if we leave while the hive mind is
[Music]
so power
if even a single Network escapes
humanity is finished
the marker
Emilia
she told me it would return the Beast to
its Lumber okay so if we return the
marker to ages seven it'll stop the
outbreak exactly
but we need the shuttle to return it to
the planet
you have a similarity
because it'll end this for good deal
excellent
I I could distract Mercer but not for
long I don't get the marker to the
shuttle Bay quickly
thank you
for helping me fix my mistakes
I don't know what's good what's bad here
I don't know what is what's was
all this seems kind of wonky to me
ignorance concerned
but so long as you let me through I
guess we're good
and you left great you left okay
all right she was only a voice of first
but now she is my constant companion
again I had forgotten how much her
presence soothe is me and all as always
she sees to the heart of the problem the
marker must be returned perhaps there's
been some kind of accident some
Severance did the marker in the hive
mind always coordinate or can the hive
mind slip the markers influence somehow
regardless if this theory is correct if
the two are now at odds if the marker
can quell The Hive mine it would cut the
Puppeteer strings how to sing at a
stroke it seems obvious in retrospect
these Necromorphs has no intelligence
how could they yet there's clear if
rudimentary purpose behind their actions
especially the Gathering of corpses
they're clearly following some drive to
kill living organisms and gather biomass
but where does this drive come from how
does it command them do all Necromorphs
converted by a marker share this Bond
pack Instinct whereas the hive mind
demonstrating a genuine telepathic
communication perhaps the first ever
observed how painful to admit that the
markers Horrors still hold a Fascination
for me now I think I understand my
predecessors those who first studied the
black marker rather better The Road to
Hell begins with unprincipled curiosity
foolish foolish foolish I should have
known sabotaging the engines was only a
stop Gap are we returning to Earth is
the marker falling back into the
church's hands yes Amelia there are
always alternate Solutions always
so the marker wants to be returned to be
made whole but these things seem to be
working kind of in the opposite retrieve
the marker where did you go
oh yeah bench I like benches
there's a lot of mamilias all over the
walls here
kind of an Amelia town this is the
mamelia corner something tells me I
don't want to I don't know stand too
closely to those bench good
upgrade node yes thank you
like more damage
I like more size
air
air good enough for me I'm kind of
approaching diminishing returns here I
really don't have anything else to do
reload speed I guess I could go towards
this
capacity as if I need capacity
it's already got 120 bullets how many
more could I possibly put in there I
don't understand how a power node is
going to make it physically bigger but
retrieve the marker okie dokie then
understood
hey look a marker
I knew that was there all along
I knew that was there
I knew that was there why
again with this
oh really oh
we're fighting in the shade
man this does not do as much damage as I
was hoping it was why are you glowing
red
wow
okay we're going back to why are they
glowing red
it definitely helped me see them why are
you glowing red why is any of this
glowing red
whatever
oh hell yeah
oh you
are you now install the singularity core
on the shuttle I'll come help you
he's close
run I guess
he's so scary
fascinating
power node
why am I even gonna need a power note I
I've got I'm close to my objective we're
almost done I'm almost free
this is a nice shuttle here okay oh my
God I'm on fire
ow
that hurt a lot did that Blast away my
goodies that I just yeah probably oh
well
easy come easy go you know how it is
okay hey big guy why don't we get you
loaded up on this thing
up
oh apparently not
man you uh you're dizzying to look at
in that you're so beautiful or something
oh I need to load it in the right the
core first okay core first
simularity core that's a weird place for
it considering that Hammond got blushed
into nothingness by even going near it
um installation I don't know if I feel
too confident about that
all right test fire huh
sure thing kind of weird I need to test
fire it
but oh well I do I I do as my objective
Marker set marker
hey wait a minute you're not supposed to
be there
wow
okay so what I'm gonna do
is we're gonna have a good old time
oh my God oh my God do not did you just
whoa you mutter
oh you son of a [__]
who did that
who did that wow you
sorry baby that was definitely Overkill
but uh
you really really really deserved it hey
bud is there something behind me really
okay and here we go I'm gonna test fire
you
dude I just my instincts my gamer
instincts are so good
foreign
is it weird that that the death of the
hunter looked better in the
original because you saw like each piece
of arm getting melted and Stripped Away
hey
[Music]
were you grumpy dream conversions make
us whole
says
good thing good thing this technical
stopped long enough for me to see that
ow
ow ow all right buddy it's time all
right watch this
I can't wait what am I what am I even
looking at I can't even see it I don't
have the ammo for the I was out of ammo
which was a really inconvenient timing
for that how many are you come here
beautiful come here beautiful
oh my god really oh
was that right at the
yeah that was right at that Mr Clark
Mr Clark come in [__] this [__]
you're alive
Kendra oh yeah but every alert on the
ishimura screaming critical damage to
internal systems the market just ripped
right through the ship something pulled
it down to the cargo bay behind pilot
the shovel of the hangar I'm going after
the marketer of course Amelia quickly
wait Dr kyne that guy's lost it he
killed the captain we can't trust him
near the marker
he says returning it to the planet is
the only way to end this we've gotta try
I'm ready to Cargo you paint Nicole's
rig and tell her where to go
leave it to me
thanks when I get the marker we're all
getting out of here
we're all getting out of here
that sounds pretty good to me up End of
Days
which also means
thank you everybody so much for watching
we will continue this in the next
episode and
I will see you
in the next video
bye-bye